[Music]
kaley cuoco and carl cook tied the knot
over the weekend so you think they'd be
on a romantic honeymoon right well not
exactly the case
that's Kaley catching some Z's after
having shoulder surgery Carl posted the
video to Instagram as well as this pic
with the caption everyone has their own
version of a newlywed glow well Norman
cook yours is memorable
hashtag shoulder surgery honeymoon the
32 year old actress seems to be
recovering and in good spirits she
posted videos of Carl attempting to
style her hair and watching a movie
together very excited to watch your
greatest showmen with me right now
shoulder surgery aside Kayleigh is
clearly on cloud nine after marrying
Carl in a lavish ceremony and
over-the-top reception here's what the
blonde beauty told et about her man in
November why is he so special he is
totally the guy I think the common
denominator is the horses it just works
for us you know we have this special
bond and yeah the animals and he he's as
real he's so real I've never met a
kinder human being he's gentle and he's
real and I'm completely in love with him
nothing could be better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]